اوكرانيا تكسير كافه الخطوط الحمراء في
الحرب من الارض الروسيه هذه المره فكيف
سيرد الكريملان وموسكو تدخل اقوى اسلحتها
المرعبه في الخط فالى اين المفر
للاوكرانيا والغرب بينما واشنطن تاروت
بارسال اسلحه محرمه قد تحسم المعارك في
اوكرانيا
وليس في المعارك وانما في السلطه
الاوكرانيه ما هي القصه وبوتين يحضر
مفاجات قيمه للمناطق الاوكرانيه المنضمه
الى روسيا واوكرانيا تعترف بخسائرها عن
طريق الخطا وبولندا تخترق المجال
البيلاروسي ومينس تطبخ الرد على نار هادئه
على النار في النيجر وزعم كوريا الشماليه
يجعل جارته الجنوبيه تعلن حاله التاهب
القصوى وتل ابيب تعيش فوضى حقيقيه والجيش
الاس يستنفر والعراق يعلن حاله الطوارئ
اسلحه محرمه في كياب اظلم الليل على
اوكرانيا ويبدو ان الشمس بعيده بعض الشيء
واشنطن تبث قليلا من الروح في الاوكران
لكن بطريقه محرمه وخاطئه هذه المره فها هي
وكاله رايترز تقول ان اداره الرئيس جو
بايدن تعتزم نقل شحنه من القذائف الخارقه
للذروع تحتوي على اليورانيوم المخضب الى
اوكرانيا في اول مره من نوعها بين
الامدادات العسكريه لكياف وذلك عندما تعلن
الاداره الامريكيه عن حزمه مساعدات جديده
الى كييف خلال الاسبوع المقبل متامله ان
تشكل تلك الهديه التي تعرف بقاتله
الدبابات راضيا بوجه المدرعات الروسيه
ولكن مهلا مهلا الم تعلم واشنطن ان هذه
الاسلحه محرمه لانها حتى وان لم تصب
فستستمر بتشويه المواليد وتنشر السرطان
فعن اي اضرار نتحدث لننتقل الى ما سيصاعد
الحرب اكثر فاكثر حيث كسرت اوكرانيا كافه
الخطوط الحمراء في الحرب الدائره بينها
وبين روسيا منذ اكثر من عام ونصف وذلك في
مفاجاه من العيار الثقيل حيث اعلن رئيس
المديريه الرئيسيه للاستخبارات بوزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان قوته نفذت هجوما بالطائرات المسيره على
مطار بيسكو في العسكري قرب الحدود مع
استونيا ولطيفيا من داخل روسيا وزعم ان
بلاده باتت تعمل الان من داخل الاراضي
الروسيه الامر لم ياتي من العدم وانما وفق
ما نقله المصدر وهو ما تشاهدونه امامكم
كما نتصفحه على موقع
هل من رد روسي على خطوه جريئه كهذه الرد
الروسي كالعاده لا يتاخر وهنا اعلنت روسيا
دخول صاروخ سار الجديد الملقب بالشيطان في
الخدمه وهو صاروخ قادر على حمل رؤوس
النوويه وقادر على الوصول الى اي هدف في
العالم وتدمير مدن باكملها وكما قال بوتين
ليس له مثيل ليرد مستشار مكتب الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل
مصرحا بان عدد الهجمات بالطائرات المسيره
على اراضي روسيه سيزداد وستنتقل العمليات
تدريجيا الى اراضي روسيا الاتحاديه وفق
تعبيره فيما قال رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الاوكراني ان القياده الاوكرانيه تسعى
لزياده مدى الاسلحه الهجوميه التي يبلغ
مداها حاليا 700 كم ميدانيا قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها نفذت خمسه ضربات
دقيقه ادت الى تعطيني نظام التحكم
الالكتروني الاستراتيجي للجيش الاوكراني
واضافت الوزاره ان القوات الروسيه دمرت
ورشات لتجميع المسيره البحريه المستخدمه
من قبل هجمات على الاراضي الروسيه يا لها
من ضربه قويه ولكن لابد من مصدر لتصريح
كهذا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها
نفذت خمس ضربات دقيقه ادت الى تعطيل نظام
تحكم الالكتروني الاستراتيجي للجيش
الاوكراني اضافت الوزاره ان القوات
الروسيه دمرت ورشات تجميع المسيرات
البحريه المستخدمه من قبل لشني هجمات على
الاراضي الروسيه هذا واعلنت روسيا انها
دمرت ثلاثه زوارق مسيره حاولت شن هجوم على
جسر القرم وذكرت وزاره
الدفاع ان قواتها دمرت في حدود منتصف
الليل ثالث الزوارق في البحر الاسود
اى الرسل مجددا كم على اوكرانيا ان تفقد
من الزوارق حتى تعلم ان هجمات كهذه لا
تاتي باي نتيجه سوى الاموال المدفوعه
كقيمه لهذه الزوارق وهنا يجيب المتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض جون كيربي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه حقق التقدما ملحوظا خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه خصوصا على محور
الزابوريج مشددا على ان الاولويه حاليا هي
الضمان استعداد القوات الاوكرانيه لمواصله
هذا التقدم بينما ترد روسيا باعلان
سيطرتها على مواقع اوكرانيه على مرتفعات
قرب مدينه كوبيانسك وعلى العكس تماما قالت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه في بيان لها ان
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد نجح في اختراق
الدفاعات الروسيه على محور
ليستمر الكر والفر يا ساده لتعلن الدفاع
الروسي اعتراض طائرتين مسيرتين اوكرانيتين
في مقاطعه بيل جراود جنوب غربي روسيا
مضيفه ان القوات الاوكرانيه تكبدت خسائر
فادحه في الارواح بلغت اكثر من 500 خلال
24 ساعه كما عززت القوات الروسيه مواقعها
في محور واسقطت 25 مسيره في مناطق مختلفه
واليكم المصدر كما نتصفحه في الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه بدوره اعتبر
الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديفا مثمرا وموفقا لجهه تطهير البلاد
من اولئك الذين يحاولون اضعافها من الداخل
مشيدا بجهود الضباط انفاذ القانون في هذا
الجانب وكان الضابط المتقاعد في
الاستخبارات الامريكيه قد اكد سابقا انا
واشنطن تخشى الاقرار بان معظم المساعدات
الماليه المرسله الى اوكرانيا ينتهي بها
المطاف في جيوب المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
وهنا نضع سؤالا عابرا هل يريد مسؤولون
الاوكران الانتصار في الحرب اما الاي
جيوبهم ولتذهب البلاد الى الجحيم لنكمل
فعل الطرف المقابل اعلن الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين انه سيتم تخصيص نحو 20
مليار دولار من الميزانيه الفيدراليه
لتطوير المناطق الاربعه التي تم ضمها من
اوكرانيا وقال بوتين ان السلطات ستعمل على
تطوير هذه المناطق ورفع مستويات المعيشه
والحياه فيها وبالعوده الى مسؤول واشنطن
قال المستشار السابقون دوجلاس ماكريجاب ان
القياده الاوكرانيه اقرت عن طريق الخطا
انها خسرت نحو 400 الف جنديا منذ انطلاق
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وذلك بقولهم انه
يتوجب عليهم تكريم موتاهم وذكروا نفس
العدد 400 الف عسكري ومن حرب اوكرانيا الى
حرب يكاد فتيلها ان يشتعل في اي لحظه حيث
اعلنت بيلاروسيا ان طائره الهجوميه
بولنديه اخترقت مجالها الجوي ولم تلتقط
رضاره الدفاع الجوي المروحيه بسبب
ارتفاعها المنخفض في نسخه شبه متوقعه
الحادث الذي وقع قبل بضعه اسابيع حيث دخلت
مروحيه بيلاروسيتان المجال الجوي البولندي
ولم يتم اكتشافهما ايضا فالامر بدا بالشد
والجذب والعوده الى الوراء تصعب اكثر
فاكثر وقالت وزاره الخارجيه البيلاروسيه
انها استدعت القائمه بالاعمال الفولانديه
بشان الحادث ووجهت له تحذيرا شديدا لهجه
الاحداث والتطورات قال الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون انه يتحدث يوميا مع رئيس
النيجر المعزول محمد بازام واضاف ماكرون
انه جدد التاكيد على دعم فرنسا للرئيس
محمد الذي اطيح به في الانقلاب افادت
وكاله يون هاب الكوريه الجنوبيه بان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت عده صواريخ كروز مجنحه
باتجاه البحر الاصفر فجر السبت ولم تكشف
هيئه الاركان في سيولا عن المزيد من
تفاصيل بشان الصواريخ وعددها ومداها كبيره
الى انها تجري تحليلا حاليا واكدت انها
تحافظ على حاله التاهب مع تكليف مراقبه
انشطه كوريا الشماليه بالتنسيق مع الحلفاء
وجه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بارسال قوات ضخمه لاستعاده النظام في تل
ابيب بعد احداث الشغب والتخريب التي
شهدتها المدينه والتي اصيب خلالها اكثر من
100 شخص بينهم عناصر من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه خلال مواجهات مع مئات
المهاجرين من اريتريا في تل ابيب واندلعت
الاحتجاجات بعد رفض السلطات الاسرائيليه
اقامه مهرجان للسفاره الارتريه في تل ابيب
والى العراق حيث وجه رئيس الوزراء العراقي
محمد شياع السوداني بفرض حظر التجوال في
كركوك والشروع بعمليات امنيه واسعه في
المناطق التي شهدت اعمال شغب لغرض تفتيشها
بالشكل الدقيق وشهدت محافظه كركوك صدامات
اثر اعتداءات على فرق تطوعيه تابعه لاقليم
كردستان كانت تتوجه نحو الجنوب حيث تم
رشقها وضربها بالحجاره وخلفت الصدمات قتلى
وجرحى
[موسيقى]